PROFESSOR: We have already
begun with the degenerate
perturbation theory.
And we obtained
the first result--
perhaps the most
important result--
already.
It came rather quick.
And let me review what we had.
So we were talking
about the Hamiltonian
H0 that had degeneracies.
And we were now interested to
see what the perturbation does
to those degenerate states.
What does it do to its energies?
What does it do to
the states themselves?
So we called that degenerate
subspace the space V capital N.
And the rest of the state
space of the theory was V hat.
For those states in
the degenerate space,
we use a label n for being an
n-th state or having energy En.
They all have the same energy,
unperturbed energy, En0.
These are the states.
And with k running
from 1 to n-- these
are a basis of linearly
independent states
that span the
degenerate subspace.
So that's our
And then, the rest of the
space is the space V hat.
And it's spanned by states
that we call p0's, we
used to call them.
And the notation
is good that allows
you to distinguish,
with two labels, states
in the degenerate subspace
and, with one label, a state
in the rest of the space.
The rest of the space can
also have degeneracies
that wouldn't matter.
You see, when you do
non-degenerate perturbations
theories, because
you are focusing
on a single,
non-degenerate state,
it's not that you're
focusing on a theory in which
every state is non-degenerate.
Non-degenerate
perturbation theory
means focusing on a
non-degenerate state
of a general spectrum.
Same thing with degenerate
perturbation theory.
You focus on a particular
non-degenerate space.
Whether there are other
non-degenerate spaces
doesn't matter.
They will be
treated as the rest.
And that makes your life simple.
So we had our
perturbative equations
assume that we were going
to find states nk that
depend on lambda.
And they would have energies
Enk that depend on lambda.
And looking at the
Schrodinger equation,
we found an expansion
in which this state
is the state n0 plus lambda
n1 plus lambda squared n2.
And this energy is En0
plus the first corrections
plus the second corrections
and those things.
So these were our equations
that probably by now, they're
starting to look
pretty familiar.
And as usual, we say that
a correction to a state
doesn't receive corrections.
We can work in a
convention where
it doesn't receive
corrections proportional
to the original state.
This could be reabsorbed
into normalization.
So that was the setup.
And we said we would calculate
things using three steps.
And the first step was to act
with those unperturbed states
on the order lambda equation,
so lambda to the 1 there.
The first equation
is always trivial.
So we acted in this equation.
And these states are
killed by this operator
because they are
states of energy En0.
And therefore, you get the
right-hand side equal to 0
when you have the n0l.
And we discovered that the
consistency of our expansion
requires that the chosen basis--
because, after all,
you chose that basis.
Nobody gave it to you.
If you have a
degenerate subspace,
you can take any set of
linearly independent vectors
that are orthonormal,
and that's a good basis.
It's not a uniquely
defined basis.
But in the chosen basis
that you're working with,
it must happen that
the perturbation
is diagonal-- delta lk.
And therefore, the first
order perturbations,
when you take l equal to k, is
given by this matrix element
between nk and nk.
So this is a key result,
and our first result
that in the degenerate
subspace, either you
choose a basis that diagonalizes
the perturbation to begin with,
or you compute the matrix delta
H in that degenerate subspace
and then work and
diagonalize it.
So either way, you do it.
So I want to make a couple
of remarks on this thing.
First remark is a terminology.
We can say that the degeneracy
was lifted by the perturbation.
And that's a great
thing if it happens.
We'll comment more.
It's a very nice thing if it
happens, the degeneracy lifted.
And you have the
intuition what happens.
You have these states are
all here of the same energy.
And then, if the
degeneracy is lifted--
these are four states-- then,
suddenly, one, two, three,
four, as lambda
changes, they split.
So their energies start
to become different.
And that depends
on the first energy
corrections being different for
every single one of the states.
So this means that Enk1
is different from Enl1
for the l-th state.
And for the k-th state, the
first energy corrections
are different for all
k different for l.
So for any two states that you
pick, from the list of your N--
capital N states there--
for any two states
that you pick,
their energies
must be different.
And then, the
degeneracy is lifted.
And that means that
you've found what
we will call a good
basis, a basis of states
that diagonalizes delta H.
And already, the
states have split.
You can now follow each of
them and see what happens.
You know what is
a preferred basis.
So this is nice.
And so this is our first remark.
Degeneracy is lifted
when this happens.
And this is the
case, we're going
to assume, for the
rest of the discussion,
for the first part
of the lecture,
that the degeneracy is lifted.
And then, we'll try to find
the correction to the state.
Let me comment that our first
order shifts that we have
found-- these eigenvalues--
are valid even if the
degeneracy is not lifted.
The second remark
has to do with a rule
to help you do this stuff.
This will be very useful
in about a week, when
we apply some of these
things to the hydrogen atom.
So first matter of notation--
some people use this,
I kind of like it--
a basis in VN that diagonalizes
delta H is called a good basis.
So good, bad-- it's kind of
easy to relate to those things.
So it's good.
It gives you the answer.
So we'll call it a good basis.
So here comes a question
that you want to answer.
Typically, you have some
basis that you like.
And you have a delta H.
Now, you can say, OK, do
I know that delta H is
diagonal in this basis?
Maybe I don't.
So what can I do?
I can diagonalize it and check.
But sometimes, there
is a better way,
and it helps you explain why
the matrix delta H is diagonal.
So this is a shortcut.
It's a conceptual
idea that you can
check that delta H is diagonal
without diagonalizing it.
So here it is.
So here's the rule--
"rule."
If the basis vectors are
eigenstates of a Hermitian
K with different eigenvalues--
so so far, what am I saying?
I'm bringing up a new operator.
Somebody gives you
another operator K--
Hermitian.
And then, you check
that, after all,
for this Hermitian operator,
the basis, or the basis vectors,
are eigenstates of that operator
and with different eigenvalues.
All of them have
different eigenvalues.
[MUMBLING]
And K commutes with delta
H, then the basis is good.
Basis is good.
Now, first time I heard this--
I still remember--
it seemed to me
like a very complicated rule.
Just diagonalize
and forget about it.
No.
But it actually is very helpful.
So let's explain this rule.
So K with delta H is equal to 0.
So let's assume we
have two eigenstates.
So "proof" here.
Two eigenstates-- n0p and n0q.
And the K eigenvalues are
lambda p and lambda q that
are different from each other.
So we said that the
basis states are supposed
to be eigenstates of
this Hermitian operator K
and all of them with
different eigenvalues.
So here, I wrote two states
that are part of our basis.
And I say that K eigenvalues
are lambda p and lambda q,
and they are different
from each other.
So far, so good.
So then we can form
the following--
n0p, the commutator of K
with delta H with K or K
with delta H n0q.
Consider that matrix element.
Since we say that K commutes
with delta H, this must be 0.
That operator that we've put
in between the states is 0.
So this is 0 because this is 0.
But on the other hand,
let's expand this.
This is a commutator.
So you have K times delta
H minus delta H times K.
Since it's a Hermitian
operator, the first term
K is near this state.
And being Hermitian,
you get the eigenvalue
of 8, which is lambda
p n0p delta H n0q.
That's from the first term.
And the second term is a
minus the delta H on the left.
So you get the
minus n0qp delta H.
And the K acting on the right
this time gives you lambda q.
So this is equal to lambda
p minus lambda q times n--
it's the same factor
for both terms--
delta H n0q.
OK.
So that matrix element
has been evaluated.
And it's now equal to the
product of the difference
of eigenvalues times the
matrix element of delta H.
But here, we know that
this product must be 0.
But since the two
eigenvalues are different,
this factor is not 0.
So the only possibility is
that the second factor is 0.
And you have shown,
therefore, at this moment,
since this is 0, this
implies that the n0p delta H
n0q is equal to 0 whenever
p is different from q.
And that's exactly
the statement that all
the off-diagonal elements
of delta H are 0.
So indeed, it has
been diagonalized.
Or you can, without
diagonalizing the delta H,
you can say, oh,
look at this basis.
This basis is good.
Because there is this operator--
many times it will be angular
momentum, lz, it
may be other thing--
for which all the states
have different eigenvalues.
And it commutes
with a perturbation.
So you look for an
operator that commutes
with a perturbation for
which your basis vectors
may be eigenstates.